- WELCOME TO BRICKLEBERRY PARK
AND THE 2013 RANGER GAMES.
- AAH!
- [grunts]
crowd: OOH.
[cheers and applause]
- WELL, WELL.
IF IT ISN'T WOODY JOHNSON.
I GUESS THEY'LL LET
ANY PSYCHOPATH
BACK IN THE RANGER GAMES
THESE DAYS.
[laughs]
- RADCLIFF,
I WILL RIP THE HEAD OFF
YOUR MOTHER'S ROTTEN CORPSE
AND MAKE HER GO DOWN
ON HERSELF.
HEY, WHO YOU CALLIN'
A PSYCHOPATH?
- OH, MAN, I'M MISSIN'
THE OPENING CEREMONIES.
WE GOTTA GET
THIS TRAINING STARTED.
WHAT'S FIRST?
- IRON MY LAUNDRY, BITCH.
- WHAT? HOW IS THAT
GONNA HELP ME ICE SKATE?
- HOW DARE YOU QUESTION
"CRISP SHIRT" CARRUTHERS?
NOW LET'S START
THE TRAINING MONTAGE.
THEY DON'T CALL ME "BREAKING
THE FOURTH WALL" CARRUTHERS
FOR NOTHING.
MOP THAT FLOOR.
CUT THAT SANDWICH.
WIPE MY ASS.
- I'M STILL NOT SURE
HOW BRINGING YOU
A KEG OF COLT 45
IS TRAINING TO BE--
WHAT?
I'VE BEEN DOING
ALL THESE CHORES
JUST TO SET UP
SOME STUPID PARTY?
I KNEW THAT WASN'T TRAINING.
- YOU'RE RIGHT, SON,
THAT WASN'T TRAINING.
THIS IS.
- GETTIN' DRUNK?
- MY SECRET TO SKATING
LIKE A STEED ON SPEED
IS TO DO IT WHILE [bleep] UP
AND LIQUOR AND WEED.
- IF IT RHYMES,
IT'S GOTTA BE TRUE.
[rustling]
- WHAT IS IT, BOY?
- [growls]
[both grunting]
- OH, NO.
THAT'S NOT ONE OF YOUR
REGULAR SCABS, BUDDY.
THAT STRAY HOBO BIT YOU.
- OH, NO.
OH, GOD, NO.
BITTEN BY A RABID HOBO--
SON, I'M AFRAID WE'LL
HAVE TO PUT YOUR PET DOWN.
BUT DON'T WORRY.
IT'LL BE EXTREMELY PAINFUL.
- NO!
- WELL, OKAY.
BUT IF HE SHOWS ANY SIGN,
YOU'LL HAVE TO FOLLOW
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION'S GUIDELINES
AND "CAP THAT CRACKER
IN HIS MOTHER[bleep] DOME."
[all cheering]
[puma growling]
[puma growls]
- NOW TAKING THE ICE
FOR TEAM BRICKLEBERRY,
DENZEL JACKSON.
- WHOO!
[beatboxing]
[giggles]
[vomits]
I HOPE I MADE YOU PROUD,
MR. CARRUTHERS.
- MR. CARRUTHERS?
WHY, HE DIED IN 1998.
THIS IS SILLY WILLIE.
HE HAS SEVERE LATE STAGE
ALZHEIMER'S. VERY SAD.
- THEY DON'T CALL ME
"WHERE THE [bleep] AM I?" WILLIE
FOR NOTHING.
- NOW, FOR OUR FINAL EVENT--
FOREST GYMNASTICS.
- HA! LOOK AT 'EM, MAGNUS.
YOU'VE GOT RADCLIFF
SO SCARED,
HE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE SOMEONE
TO GO UP AGAINST YOU.
THE GOLDEN ACORN
IS AS GOOD AS OURS.
[laughs maniacally]
- YOU GUYS, I'M REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT STEVE.
I CAN'T FIND HIM ANYWHERE.
- COMPETING FOR
TEAM BRICKLEBERRY,
THE SWISS FIST...
MAGNUS BLICKENSDERFER.
[cheers and applause]
AND FOR TEAM YELLOWSTONE,
THE RANGER OF DANGER
STEVE WILLIAMS.
- WHAT'S UP, BITCHES?
[all groaning]
- [gasps] STEVE,
WHAT DID YOU DO TO YOURSELF?
- I TOOK A SHIT-TON
OF STEROIDS,
LIKE YOU TOLD ME TO.
- I NEVER TOLD YOU
TO DO THAT.
- YOU IMPLIED IT.
AND NOW LOOK AT THE STEVE--
HE'S RIPPED!
- DID YOU WORK OUT AT ALL?
- YOU HAVE TO WORK OUT?
WHAT THE HELL GOOD
ARE STEROIDS THEN?